let's go
[Music]
what are you doing I love that show when
I was a kid Jerry no need to watch The
Love Boat we're aboard the Real Love
Boat let's go
well this is awesome this Wednesday
night fall premieres continue with the
launch of the new dating Adventure
series The Real Love Boat it's inspired
by the Beloved 1970 series The Love Boat
the new series set aboard a luxury
Mediterranean Cruise brings together
singles looking for a second chance at
love and romance and here to tell us
more about the premiere of The Real Love
Boat we are in for a treat we have crew
members from the show itself we have the
captain Paolo arigio hello we have the
bartender Ezra Freeman and the cruise
director Matt Mitchum
okay this is really exciting for so many
reasons bringing back the iconic show
but putting in this new Twist of dating
and reality so we gotta get right to it
tell us all about it what can people
expect Ezra I'll come to you first okay
well this show I think it's unlike
anything we've seen before because we've
really combined many different genres
with the Real Love Boat you have the
Nostalgia of The Love Boat you have
dating shows which everybody loves then
you have the travel aspect and even
challenges so it's kind of there's
something for everyone and I can't wait
for people to see it is it different
finding love at Sea versus Finding Love
on land yeah absolutely it really is you
know on on land you've got like you can
go check them on social media do a full
background search on them right really
get to know them on a ship you get to
really know the real person right and
there is no hiding and you can actually
be whoever you want to be on a cruise
ship and that kind of makes it fun and
we're excited for the host of the show
Jerry O'Connell and his wife Rebecca
Romaine he's actually come by here
before we love Jerry he's such a fun guy
what was it like working alongside the
two of them I mean they are power couple
goals yeah I mean and I'll take these
one guys
um they are amazing because the way you
see Jerry on TV is exactly how he's
probably no more and the thing that
struck us most when he got onto the set
on the very first day he went and shook
everybody's end technicians lightings it
is such an amazing guy I mean and
Rebecca as well you know such an honor
you know to have worked me with them at
all these guys are stunning good looking
cast here yeah I mean I watched the
original Love Boat I mean you'd I mean
the beautiful people right here did you
watch the original Love Boat and Ezra
did you meet uh Ted Lang I sure do oh my
gosh okay I am a huge fan of the show
because being a Princess Cruises crew
member it's one of the like few options
that are always on the crew TVs at all
hours of the night so Love Boat kind of
became my comfort show a few years ago
when I joined the fleet and then to
actually meet Ted and kind of Step into
the threads if you will it was amazing
he is such a lovely human and he really
took me under his wing showed me the
ropes of being you know the real Love
Boat bartender from the literal real
bartender himself so such a special
experience and he is even better in
person I would have to say how cool a
full circle
actual cruise ship workers right you
know better than anyone what it's like
to live on a cruise ship and what's it
like to find love on a cruise ship what
are we gonna see unfold in front of us
that's what's cool and I think for both
of us we actually found real love on a
cruise ship as well right so it was
really neat to kind of take what we've
learned over the last 15 years on a ship
and actually put it into these singles
and watch them kind of get together it's
really exciting we got about 30 seconds
where you all found in real love so you
all found your partners on a cruise ship
well did it I've met many of my exes
Matt you met your your wife I did yeah
yeah we met six years ago on board a
ship and the same Captain yeah so it's
true you can find love at Sea absolutely
like it's a done deal I mean Apollo
you're no Captain student my gosh you
blew him out of the water with your
looks fantastic
it's amazing you guys this show is going
to be so much fun and I'm a sucker for
any sort of dating reality show but just
to have everything again come full
circle we can't wait to see you guys on
the screen and thanks for visiting us
out here
thank you guys we appreciate it thank
you so much so the Real Love Boat set
sail this Wednesday that's October 5th
at 9pm right here on channel 8. oh I'm
excited for that